it's puzzling the brexit debate Brussels
is so concerned the UK may decide it's
game over that the Commission avoids the
word brexit wherever they can the
European Commission here behind me
Europe's powerful executive has decided
to stay silent they try not to openly
support the remain campaign says the
chief spokesperson this is now up to the
British people and the British people
alone officially I'm told there is no
plan be any post suitable scenarios
could be perceived as brexit
scaremongering but it's an open secret
all high-level British civil servants
would lose their jobs this man for
instance Jonathan Hill the British EU
commissioner the man in charge of
financial services would be among the
first to leave followed by this man
robbed Wainwright the British director
of Europol they'ii use law enforcement
agency and then they are of course the
foot soldiers the British civil servants
over 1200 of them in the European
Commission and the staff of 73 British
EU lawmakers here in the European
Parliament the lower ranks are likely to
keep their jobs but fully eventually hit
a glass ceiling experts say the UK would
lose all its influence in Brussels out
means out my overall estimation is is
that it would be will be a rough ride
that other member states will not give
the UK london and easy way out because
they fear of a domino effect of water
would what signal would send if one
leaves decides to leave and then can
cherry pick whatever and that they would
that others might follow suit for UK
citizens in Brussels this uncertainty is
already very real Francesca jenna works
as a consultant to the EU institutions
and can be candid how it feels like to
have a British passport in Brussels at
the moment a very strange talk
aim to be in Brussels I think everyone
is hoping for a positive outcomes
everybody's really hoping that
the british public will go to remain but
there is a very sort of unsettling edge
knowing that yeah they could leave could
happen she worries about future red tape
on the european job market if she loses
the privileges of EU citizenship so for
her it's clear where this part of the
puzzle belongs in the EU in yes
definitely